okay Better Call Saul actor Carrie
Condon is returning to her Irish roots
in the new movie The Banshees of Innis
Sharon she has already received a Golden
Globe nomination for her role in the
film it follows Colin Farrell and
Brandon Gleason as two lifelong friends
who find themselves at a Crossroads when
their friendship unexpectedly ends and
it's painful to watch Condon plays feral
sister Siobhan here's a look
what are you doing home
brother
what are you doing home
I knocked on column Sony Larry he's just
sitting there
sitting there doing nothing
smoking
was he asleep
he was smoking Siobhan how do you smoke
in your sleep like
have you been rowing
we haven't been around
I think we've been wrong
why wouldn't he ask the door to me
maybe he just doesn't like you no more
if maybe he doesn't like you anymore
Kerry can't enjoyed this now Carrie
thank you so much for being here this
role was written specifically for you
what struck you about the character
um I suppose initially I'll be honest it
was very different to the characters
that I played in Martin's plays and so I
was like oh it's not as much fun as
married and the lieutenant to finish
more or some of the other characters
I've played of Martins but then as I
started to kind of read it and go
through it a bit more and plan what I
was going to do I started to think that
it was actually a bit harder
because it was kind of for a more mature
girl like I don't think I could have
done it if I was 18 or 19 I feel like it
needed all these years of like learning
things about life and disappointments
and sadness and stuff and so and then it
was also just the opportunity to get to
do another big part for Martin but uh in
a movie so I knew you know would reach
more audiences than the plays had done
so yeah I was super excited and grateful
it's a really great movie uh the scenes
are great like the location is great uh
the clothes are great uh it's very funny
uh and also I love the drama at the
center of it over this this male
friendship where one of the two friends
I don't want to give up too much uh
thinks the other one has become dull yes
pretty amazing uh so you got a Golden
Globe nomination uh as the the sister in
this drama uh how did it feel when he
got that news it was gosh because I'll
be honest with you the morning I knew
they were coming out that morning but
like I forgot on the morning I kept
pressing snooze because I'd slept
desperate that I before so then when I
why is my alarm going off when it
finally I turned it on I was bombarded
with like a million trillion people and
then I found myself for hours replying
to people who hadn't spoken to in 10
years or something I thought what am I
doing I haven't even talked about I was
just trying to be nice to everyone and I
hurt anyone's feelings by not replying
so it took me days for it to kind of
sink in
um but yeah of course like I'm so
thrilled yeah Tony mentioned the
location
um edit Sharon is not a real place but
the island of inishmore is where you
shot I mean this is beautiful so what
was it like shooting at a location oh
it's gorgeous Lads it was so gorgeous
it's real spiritual I thought it was
kind of spiritual like children nature
sometimes eyes pink sometimes you can
feel like if I see a beautiful sunset or
something I sometimes think it's like a
dead person going hey Carrie yeah look
at this beautiful thing or it just kind
of makes me feel like connected and I
felt like that when I was there and all
the people in the island were really
sweet and lovely and I'm still kind of
in touch with some of them she had a
baby recently and there was two little
kids who lived near me were super cute
so I loved the whole time there yeah but
I mean you know isolating yourself
there's pluses and minus of course you
could go a little mental and nobody'd
know you know as as you as the accent
comes out and you call us Lads which by
the way are loving listening to YouTube
well I hope you don't mind being called
to let oh I love it okay good because
it's just the way I talk and I hope
anybody's thinking what isn't that
amazing I can hear you talking another
thing I love about the movie is uh the
curse words which I'm told I cannot say
on TV even in an Irish accent but they
are so great I'm going to be cursing in
Irish all weekend
it is so so good and you had a co-star
who was a donkey what was that like
little Jamie yeah she was adorable she's
like a little miniature donkey but it
was even cuter because she had to have a
friend with her so there was actually
yes two dogs
when they get lonely that's why they try
to come in the house and there was the
other donkey was called Rosie and she
was a bit older so Jenny be like well if
Rosie's here it's gotta be okay you know
I'll be fine so Rosie really held it
together for her so I kind of made you
know a big thing about Rosie because
even though she wasn't the star but we
would have been lost without it Rosie
yeah and it's a movie about friendship
and Donkey friendship is part of it as
well let's dedicate this interview to
Rosie I think yeah
the understudy oh my God yes Kerry
Condon thank you so much thanks for
having me the Banshees of Innis Sharon
is in theaters now